herzlich willkommen in meine taten
heute kommt ein zweites herbst special
ich werde heute ein zucchini brot machen
das kann man ganz gut als beilage
verwenden zu einer suppe oder zu einem
salat
ich hab das rezept in der buch gefunden
als ich mal in einem laden so durch die
bücher gestöbert habe hat mir ganz gut
gefallen
statt der zucchini könnt ihr natürlich
auch kürbis benutzen oder ihr könnt
karotten benutzen
ich zeige euch jetzt einmal die zutaten
für den teig und zeigt euch dann geht es
weiter geht
für den teig braucht ihr 500 gramm mehl
da habe ich jetzt kein 405 was sondern
ein 550 er aber ein 45 war geht
natürlich auch also ein ganz normales
weizenmehl 1 halben würfel hefe das
reichte es für den teig enthaltenen
esslöffel zucker einen esslöffel salz
inhalten esslöffel thymian getrockneten
ich habe es hier eine zucchini ich
brauche später davon etwa 200 gramm
dann brauche ich noch etwa 2 3 esslöffel
olivenöl 100 gramm pasta annimmt da
bitte auf jeden fall den frischen und
ich brauche etwas warmes wasser ich habe
jetzt hier 250 milliliter zuerst einmal
kümmert ihr euch um die zucchini die
muss nämlich jetzt geraspelt werden
so sieht das ganze dann aus und da gebe
ich jetzt die hälfte des salzes mit dazu
vermischt es einmal ganz kurz und das
lasse ich jetzt einfach so stehen damit
es die feuchtigkeit aus der zucchini
rauskam und ich sie später ausdrücken
kann
und das dauert etwa eine halbe stunde
meine zucchinis die stehen jetzt hier
schon 15 minuten es sieht auch hier ganz
deutlich dass schon etwas flüssigkeit
rauskommt die lässt sich jetzt noch etwa
eine viertelstunde stehen kann aber
schon den teig vorbereiten und zwar
gegen
mein mehl in eine schüssel dann kommt da
so eine mulde reihen
dann gebe ich da etwas von meinem wasser
rein so etwa die hälfte rösler dann die
hefe mit dazu und versuchte so ein
bisschen zu verrühren dass sich die hefe
auflöst und da kommt jetzt noch der
zucker mit rein und das bitte ich jetzt
mit dem mehl vom rand und lass das ganze
abgedeckt mit einem küchentuch an einem
warmen ort etwa eine viertelstunde gehen
in der zwischenzeit weil ich jetzt schon
mal ein paar usa das mache ich einfach
mit seiner antreiben parmesan geschmack
nicht so gern möchte kann den parmesan
auch durch einen anderen käse ersetzen
ihr könnt zum beispiel auch väter
benutzen das hätte ich das nächste mal
testen oder vielleicht einfach nur ein
toter oder er ersetzt einfach einen teil
des darms als durch kauder ich finde
mich dass der papa sein geschmack shop
richtig stark ist
also wir mögen den meine tochter macht
ihn auch aber es könnte sein dass sie
den parmesan geschmack nicht so sein
mögt dann könnte das einfach durch
irgendeinen anderen käse ersetzen sobald
die hefe dann vorbereitet ist das sieht
man einfach daran dass sie ebenso
bläschen bildet und eben aufgegangen ist
können jetzt alle zutaten rein als
schwitzt restliche salz mit rein thymian
den parmesan vorstelle ich noch kurz zur
seite möchte erst noch die zucchini
fertig machen und zwar nehmt ihr euch
jetzt die zucchini und drückt sie etwas
aus da kommt nochmal so viel flüssigkeit
raus und die gilt der dann mit zum teil
jetzt seht ihr hier auch wie viel
flüssigkeit da jetzt raus kommt die
meisten leute würden das jetzt weg
hippen und wegschütten das steht auch
normalerweise im originalrezept so drin
ich möchte es allerdings nicht weil ich
einfach denkt dass die meisten vitamine
mit drin sind und die ganzen
mineralstoffe
deswegen gebe ich jetzt dass die
flüssigkeit dazu und die meisten menge
jetzt fragen wieso ich dann die zucchini
überhaupt entwässert habe und zwar aus
dem grund ich habe das jetzt vorher
gemacht damit die flüssigkeit aus
zucchini rauskommt und nicht später wenn
der teig fertig ist und ich den dann
noch mal gehen lasse dass sie sich dann
nicht absetzt im teig und deswegen habe
ich jetzt hier die flüssigkeit wieder
mit rein gegeben damit die eben nicht
verschwendet wird und gebe jetzt noch
ein klein wenig wasser mit rein lasst
den teig erstmal verrühren und schaue ob
ich noch flüssigkeit braucht oder nicht
wenn jedes projekt nach machen wollt
dann müsst ihr die flüssigkeit nicht
ausdrücken das entwässern würde ich
allerdings empfehlen eben damit ihr seht
wie viel flüssigkeit in der zucchini ist
und damit sie eben jetzt die flüssigkeit
abgibt und nicht später wenn dann der
teig in der form drin ist dann besser
ist es nämlich so an der oberfläche
ich weiß es einfach mal schauen wie viel
flüssigkeit ich dann noch brauchbar
wetter eben noch warmes wasser mir dazu
geben wenn nötig und sag euch dann
einfach wie viel sitzt bei mir war aber
er müsste die genaue wassermenge einfach
davon abhängig machen wie viel wasser
eben in eurer zucchini enthalten waren
ihr könnt ihr jetzt sehen dass ich ein
ziemlich weichen hefeteig hab das habe
ich jetzt absichtlich so gemacht ich
habe jetzt etwa 400 milliliter wasser
mit rein
es habe jetzt so gemacht weil ich einen
teig in einer kastenform backen möchte
er sein brot aber ohne form backen
möchte lässt den teig eben fester also
gibt dann nur etwa 250 milliliter wasser
mit rein detail muss ich jetzt
allerdings noch mal gehen lassen und
zwar mache ich das wieder in warmen
backofen als ich mache den backofen
immer auf 40 grad
schaut ihn damit er aus und gibt dann
meinen teil zum ausruhen rein den denke
ich jetzt mit einem geschirrtuch und
lasst ihn gehen wie sie sich etwa
verdoppelt hat das dauerte etwa eine
halbe stunde meint eick sieht jetzt so
aus
und jetzt habe ich auch gemerkt dass ich
das olivenöl vergessen habe die zwei bis
drei esslöffel gebe ich jetzt hier
einfach ein bisschen oben drauf und kann
es noch mal so ein bisschen einrühren
das reicht schon
und ich nehme jetzt hier eine kastenform
aus silikon von durch ich denke die
kastenform ist ganz gut ich habe es noch
nicht ausprobiert aber allein schon wenn
man die in der hand hat also die stadt
stabile ich denke da läuft ja auch nicht
hier am rand raus weil viele kasten
formen haben wir das problem dass
einfach zu weich sind
und dann hier aus denen da habe ich
keinen kasten mehr sondern eher so ein
rundes unbestimmbaren irgendwas ich
werde jetzt hier drin mal machen die
form hat eine länge von 25 zentimetern
und ihr solltet generell wenn ihr mit
silikon backformen arbeitet einfach
darauf achten dass die form stabil genug
ist nicht mal die hand rein ob sie sich
leicht verformen lässt oder ob sie eben
einfach stabil bleibt und in form bleibt
dann befürchte ich meine hand etwas und
streicht den teig hielt und so gebe ich
das ganze jetzt bei 180 190 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 60 70 minuten in den
backofen bis ich eine schöne goldbraun
oberfläche habe und zeigt euch dann das
ergebnis so sieht es jetzt aus mainz
gebracht
und das kann man als ganz einfach aus
der form herauslösen
ich habe schon ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen und dann zeige ich mich auch wie
das aussieht muss anschneidet desto
stand praktisch ist groß also dass
packung in der silikonform hat wirklich
sehr gut geklappt ich bin sehr zufrieden
mit der form auch weil sie sich so
einfach reinigen lässt wir hatten mal
vor jahren als die ersten silikon formen
raus kam hatten wir die mal gekauft und
meiner mutter und mir hat es so absolut
gar nicht gefallen also mir hat auch der
kuchen nicht geschmeckt städter drin
gebacken wurde
ich taste mich jetzt mal so langsam
wieder heran so gerade für brot und
firma finde ich nämlich silikonen
förmchen eigentlich ganz praktisch weil
sie einfach schnell sauber zu machen
sind
und weil immer einfach weniger papier
braucht gerade bei muffin förmchen und
wenn ihr den teig ohne form von gold als
es als brotlaib dann müsste wie gesagt
den teig fester machen damit ihr ihn
schon fahren könnt ich hoffe dieses
rezept gefällt euch und ihr werdet es
mal ausprobieren
ich freue mich auf jeden fall über eure
kommentare und über eine bewertung und
morgen ist dann schon wieder weiter mit
einem anderen rezept erzählen wir sie
morgen schon wieder
und dann sage ich mal tschüss und viel
spaß